muchas gracias señor embajador feliz de
estar aquí y de poder simplemente decir
unas cuantas palabras antes de contestar
a sus preguntas y después de lo que
dijeron el señor baile en el señora
merkel
ustedes nos lanzan un desafío que es
saber cómo la alianza transatlántica y
como occidente puede ser útil creo que
tenemos un destino común y un rol
histórico aquí hoy y simplemente
quisiera compartir dos grandes ideas la
primera cosa que debemos hacer me parece
entre estadounidenses y europeos que nos
encontramos de nuevo con una voluntad
común de avanzar y compartir los mismos
valores lo primero es tener un
multilateralismo que produzca resultados
que sea útil en términos de clima
la señora merkel lo dijo perfectamente
en términos de preservación de nuestras
democracias y particularmente cuando se
trata de preservar la libertad de
expresión y evitar el regreso del odio a
las democracias y el tema también de la
regulación de lo digital también se
presenta que creo que también es vital
para las democracias también es el tema
del trato de las inequidades porque creo
que si queremos hacer que la
mundialización tenga éxito y en
particular la de occidente no vamos a
lograrlo sin hacerlo sin los vecinos de
particular áfrica tenemos que arreglar
las inequidades en nuestras sociedades y
con los vecinos es la respuesta
económica a esta crisis nuestra agenda
con áfrica nuestra agenda con el fmi
para tener derechos especiales
y también la red reestructuración de las
deudas africanas y también es nuestra
agenda en términos de salud aquí también
estoy totalmente de acuerdo con lo que
dijo el presidente by denny la canciller
merkel tenemos un desafío colectivo ya
pasamos las primeras etapas para
coordinarnos para proteger nuestras
poblaciones lograr innovar de manera
inédita para inventar nuevos vacunas y
ahora implementarlas en nuestros países
creo que si queremos lograr este
multilateralismo que produzca resultados
el desafío que tenemos enfrente es entre
estadounidenses y europeos permitir a
todos los países del mundo pobres y
emergentes acceder de manera más rápida
posible al diagnóstico y también a las
vacunas y a mejorar su sistema de salud
está en la iniciativa act
lanzada en marzo de 2020 con la
organización mundial de la salud es el
desafío que es el nuestro el día de hoy
y en el g7 anunciamos sumas importantes
creo que es un paso importante pero hay
una idea muy simple que estoy
defendiendo después de
a partir con nuestros socios africanos
el continente africano tiene 6.5
millones de personas en personal de
salud y se necesitan estas dosis de
vacuna para permitir que el sistema
resista si nosotros sabemos que estas 13
millones de dosis son representa nuestra
credibilidad y representan 0.43 por
ciento de las dosis que tenemos lo que
hemos pedido si sabemos hacer eso
entonces occidente tendrá una presencia
y será considerado en áfrica si
anunciamos que vamos a anunciar que
vamos a dar dosis dentro de seis meses o
un año nuestros compañeros africanos van
a tener mucha presión y ya habrán
comprado las dosis a los rusos o los
chinos oa otros laboratorios
directamente la fuerza de occidente o de
los europeos y estadounidenses será un
concepto pero no una realidad entonces
es una idea muy concreta y muy rápida el
segundo pilar creo yo para nuestro
destino y trabajo común
entre europeos y estadounidenses es
construir una agenda de seguridad
angela merkel lo dijo en detalle sobre
las diferentes situaciones regionales en
el comparto todo lo que dijo
entonces no voy a repetir lo que ya ella
dijo de manera perfecta en la agenda de
seguridad común en el fondo tenemos tres
cosas que hacer la primera es construir
reconstruir la agenda y la arquitectura
de seguridad juntos es decir el nuevo
concepto de la otan yo creo que todo lo
que les dije el año pasado sigue siendo
válido en las preguntas las dudas lo que
se lo que hizo un comité es el rol de
los gobiernos de los jefes de estados
para poder preparar un nuevo concepto
que va a estructurar nuestra acción en
la otan en los próximos años y va a
construir las bases de esta arquitectura
de seguridad de arquitectura de
seguridad común es un diálogo con rusia
que no debe ser que debe ser exigente y
que se haga la base para que europa
pueda vivir en paz
lo segundo es poder fijar las arreglar
las situaciones regionales en sahel
donde estamos muy presentes y combatimos
el dinamismo en irak con una situación
increíblemente importante siria o
también en nagorno karabaj
el mediterráneo oriental todas estas
cosas para construir seguridad y cómo
podemos manejar esto de manera conjunta
de manera coordinada respetando a todos
los aliados de manera absoluta lo cual
no siempre ha sido el hecho y como
avanzamos juntos para resolver estas
situaciones entre aliados pero también
entre miembros permanentes del consejo
de seguridad entre socios para poder
justamente construir soluciones comunes
irán por supuesto será también una
situación importante y el tercer gran
desafío que es el nuestro es mantener lo
que yo llamaría la libertad de la
soberanía y mantener la libertad de la
soberanía es una
la frase que me robó de un ministro de
australia para definirla
lo que tenemos que hacer en el
ciberespacio en el espacio y en el
espacio marítimo marítimo porque son
nuevas zonas de conflicto para defender
la libertad de la soberanía es estar
presentes para preservar estos espacios
y es también el centro de nuestra agenda
común en términos de indo-pacífico no
tenemos los mismos enfoques en esta
noción pero creo yo que el objetivo que
debemos seguir en esta región es la
libertad de la soberanía resolver
conflictos regionales conservar los
grandes espacios la soberanía de cada
uno y construir una arquitectura de
seguridad de confianza creo yo son los
elementos